the Joe Rogan experience do if you I
think if you like any age is funny
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yourself is funny
yeah except when you're really old then
it's sad no what I'm saying is if you're
80 and you heard that story you'd still
laugh yes not if it happened to you when
you were 80 if you happen to when you're
a then it says especially if you're a
lady like I'm an 85 year old man and I
[ __ ] myself feel free to laugh sure we
have your permission yeah
but old ladies it's like oh the last
time I I've never I've only [ __ ] myself
once and I was I think 11 that's yes
you're not taking enough chances I have
almost [ __ ] myself and just made it so
many times but the last time I almost
[ __ ] myself and I had to pull over and
was when I was going to meet mmm
[Laughter]
smelling like [ __ ] no underwear on and
then you have to figure out what to do
so that you take your socks off wipe
yourself when I'm not wearing socks and
and and so I was in this the Sprinter
van and we were going you know I was on
tour so I had the Sprinter van and we
were going to the how did that whole
thing happens because you make fun of
them yeah and so he thought it was funny
right so I was at my old house this was
maybe two years ago at this point and I
was in the driveway I don't remember
what I was doing but I was waiting for
something and it had been right around
the time where like Eminem's album came
out or something so he was on my mind
and I was like I was thinking about him
and then I was just like this is how he
raps and then I just started doing it to
the radio and I was like I was funny I'm
gonna record it and then I recorded it
one time and it was just like that's
funny I'll put it online and I put it
online and it got you know traction for
me it was like it had a lot of hits for
me on my Instagram and I was like cool
great
and then like a month later black
Twitter took it and just was like yo
this is this guy
says this is how they didn't know nobody
knew I was what they were like this is
this guy says this is how Eminem raps
and then it got millions of things of
hits on Twitter and then it got so big
my buddies were like you think Eminem
has probably seen it right and I was
like it's so big maybe one of his
buddies must have seen it and showed him
and then like a week or two later
my buddy texted me one of the writers
from that show I used to do undateable
and he was like bro Eminem and I was
like what and he was like you didn't see
it check Twitter and I checked and he
was like I thought this was me and I was
like what like that's like if you told
the 20 year old me that Eminem was gonna
and then he started being like I will
bat rap battle Chris D'Elia won don't
know if you saw that yeah I didn't see
that yeah he was like I'm gonna rap out
of Crystal via one day and I'm like am I
in the hip-hop game now and and and and
then I don't know how much you know
about this but then logic the rapper hit
me up well my manager called me and he
was like hey so look you know logic is
an oh man my every manager has that
voice look Josh Lieberman so I don't
know if you know the logic and rapper
and of course I do
and he was like alright so look he's
doing a song on Eminem and he they are
rapping together and I mean him Eminem
put you your impression Eminem on the
back of the song and they're wondering
if that's okay hey and I was like of
course that's okay and here's like imma
look into it and see I'm like no no
don't ask for any money just let them
have it
are you kidding me that this is even
happening he was like okay okay and so
then he comes back he's like analodjica
wants your number I was like yeah okay
so I'm talking to logic and logic Sykes
so I have a great idea for the video I
want you to play Eminem in this vid you
seen this video no no I wish I know
everyone google it but we're looking at
it on the screen
yeah oh you could see it right but not
play it so this isn't so I'm playing
Eminem in this
do i rap his part and now this is the
crazy part okay so like I'm talking to
logic here and I play this like super
fan of Eminem and he's like I have an
idea
I want we're doing a video and I'm like
I'm Way ahead of you go ahead this is
we're way ahead eeeh and then I take off
my wig and I've always been an Eminem
like Stan and this is me doing you gotta
watch this video so so I'm doing this
video as Eminem right and we shoot this
and then at the end you've seen the
video where I do the impression of Eman
yeah at the end the Lea doesn't play me
I played Lea this is Eminem dressed as
me
that's Eminem doing me in my car in my
driveway two years ago but so and and
like to think of me as a 20 year old
like thinking like finding out who
Eminem was and then him becoming one of
my favorite rappers of course and then
it's just such a weird [ __ ] thing
so that was mind-blowing and then on the
way to meet him I [ __ ] my [ __ ] eye I
had to pull the Sprinter van over and he
has no idea but dude it was so funny I
it was just one of those things where I
was like I think you know how you have
you're like I think I have to [ __ ] and
the next thought is I got a [ __ ] right
now I mean there's no thinking involved
it's a oh it turned into Oh exactly
right so I say to the Sprinter to the
driver I say hey buddy um can you pull
off the freeway I got a in my head I'm
like I got time if there's a bathroom
near right so I'm like can you pull over
and and and find the first place I gotta
go to the bathroom and he says okay and
then a few seconds go by and I say hey
just so you know like now you know and
it cuz i got work anon something here i
got and he says sure enough that no
problem so he pulls off and and there
are two ways he can go and one way he
can go there is only a
Hospital okay and the other way he can
go is into town so I'm like in my head
I'm like it sucks but we gotta go to the
hospital use the bathroom in the
hospital and I'm gonna run in they're
gonna think something's wrong but I'm
just gonna be like where's the bathroom
I gotta go
this guy goes the other way into town to
find a gas station so now I'm mad so I
have to [ __ ] and I'm mad so I say to the
guy hey man um pull over and he pulls
over and I open the thing and there were
Kleenex there I grabbed them and I ran
into someone's yard it was in the middle
of nowhere dude it was in it we were
going on our way to Detroit and I and
and I was in someone's yard a rep I
found trees thank God pulled down my
pants and it all came out quick and and
it was diarrhea or is it [ __ ] it was not
it was not [ __ ] it was not [ __ ] it was
just it came out it was just like right
came out like a barking dog and it was
over it was over before it even started
you know and and I was another so much
better and then I used the Kleenex and
my openers in the in the in the thing
filming me I'm like bro I swear to God
if that ends up on Instagram I will
[ __ ] you're done you're done you're
done you're done and not only that
you're not meeting Eminem was that just
in some random guys yard and and so so
now I feel great I wipe with the Kleenex
and I just I'm sorry I littered but I
left the clinic so what am I gonna do
what are you and it was a it was a lot
and I was like and I will and I left I
got back anything I was like that was
amazing I was like somebody's gonna
think there was a [ __ ] bobcat in
their yard like I just and we went and
we met Eminem and he had no idea
maybe he'll know now sure you've seen
the show but yeah myself on the way to
[ __ ] Eminem so I don't really care
that is [ __ ] myself you know what I
mean because I got outside and did it
yeah it's a gray area
[Applause]